right hook to the face again won't be
able to take many more of those
[Applause]
come fight night I don't want him
growing in the town so after a day's
rest I've decided to see how he copes in
the ultimate test of stamina a conveyor
belt of fresh spawn partners known as
the shark tank every minute he faces a
fresh opponent as you get to that wall
you can go through that wall you can
push yourself even more it's gonna feel
like hell he's got understand it's gotta
keep going
smokey pushing six boats later Idris is
still standing there was opportunities
we like I couldn't and that's the
important thing you're seeing gaps now
you never saw them before you just
proved for the sake of it for sure
best mate Warren himself a former
champion Thai boxer has been scouting
for a suitable opponent we want this to
be a real fight you know as fair as
possible Lionel do you know around those
days he's picked one of the most
experienced fighters in Mike's gym
Lionel graves Lionel has been fighting
as a pro for 16 years with ten fights
and only two defeats on his record he
has far more experience than Idris and
he's much younger only 32 I think
there's gonna be the fight of my life
before the fight takes place the
European president of the international
sport kickboxing Association must judge
whether the two fighters are a good
match my claim that it's not a real
fight I wouldn't be here if it's not a
real fight because I'm staking my
reputation on this I'm the president and
the credible organization it's going to
be a great fight but it's definitely
going to be real you could feel the
tension in the room law and all that
confidence but you shouldn't
underestimate interests it's a dangerous
thing to do
as far as I was concerned he was just a
bag and I was gonna here but then when I
looked in his eyes I saw another guy
another bloke
and I thought to myself you know what I
can actually beat this guy
idris could be about to suffer the
biggest humiliation of his life in front
of a capacity crowd of 1200 and the
world's press
I just need to remember to keep calm if
I can do that
might be another chance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
come along no way to get here I'm just
going to fight mine just give it my own
[Applause]
Varnum came out all guns blazing or
worried free dress way through the first
round and Alber is way behind on points
the right hook to the face again won't
be able to take many more of those elder
fights back
but he's got to watch those legs he just
was hurt by low kicks was getting caught
with some big knees and some big punches
[Applause]
Elba has got to stay focus
he can't allow graves to break him Elvis
frustrated graves just won't give him
room to work as he applies the pressure
you
[Music]
you